hosers let's talk about voting it's as
American as apple pie flavored slim jims
when you go to the polls this fall
you'll see mainstream candidates boring
you'll see outsider candidates also
boring you'll see ferrell conservative
candidates who will rip out the
establishments throat and bury it in the
backyard the good guys so we're here to
celebrate the brave man and brave mostly
men who are running on the fringe
welcome to fringe watch 2018 the fringe
candidates they're no longer on the
fringe look at the fringe guy fringe
friends embrace parts of the freeze
[Music]
20:18 whoa I am with that gorilla we had
to fire six writers to pay for that
graphic but it was as worth it as joke
TBD
first up Republican Joe Arpaio banned
king of the hill character and Arizona
Senate candidate infamous former sheriff
Americo Poe County Arizona Joe Arpaio
ignored a court order to stop
unconstitutionally racially profile
people and was then convicted of
criminal contempt of court when he
ignored them only to be subsequently
pardoned by President Trump yeah a Trump
didn't even mean to pardon Arpaio he
thought it was a Thanksgiving turkey who
also hates Mexicans Arpaio is totally on
the fringe or at least he was until Vice
President and chastity robot Michael
Pence praised Arpaio as a champion of
the rule of law yes that's how you
champion something by completely
disobeying it that's why I'm a champion
of Denny's no shirt no shoes rule eggs
just taste better that way you know what
still not fringy enough what else you
got whoa boom dan Fisher who is running
for governor in Oklahoma like our piyo
this Republican is committed to
upholding all the laws that he feels
like upholding what you've explained in
this cheerful campaign ad I'm running
for governor to establish proper
government and assert state sovereignty
to abolish human abortion yes
exactly it's only human abortion he
wants to abolish Planned Parenthood is
welcome to keep its doors open and for
all you history nerds defending the
legality of abortion by pointing to roe
v-- wade fishers got a simple philosophy
when the courts are wrong they should be
ignored yeah ignoring the courts always
works that's how I got these sick new
rims on my car for rule breakers only
but if running for government on the
platform of ignoring the government
isn't fringe enough Fisher also dresses
up like a Hamilton understudy and gives
talks about the black robes regiment a
group of 18th century pastors who
encourage rebellion and not the special
ops team from Handmaid's Tale although
that is Dan Fisher's vision for Oklahoma
you know what we can do better
fridge me up to eleven how about cash
Jackson Libertarian candidate for
Illinois governor and half man half belt
buckle and yes cash Jackson is what he
goes by and yes that's how it's spelt
and it makes sense once you learned that
he legally changed it from Benjamin
winter wheedle Benjamin winter we know
that name looks at Benedict Cumberbatch
and says hold my monocle
now jackson's main issue is father's
rights and totally unrelated
he was just ordered to pay his ex-wife
over $10,000 in child support nothing
says I can take care of a whole state
like not paying for your kids dentist
appointments but there's more according
to his wife Jackson bullied his two
youngest kids by forcing one to stack
bricks in the cold at the age of six and
making both kids do push-ups in the snow
I know I know that sounds bad but hey
those kids will think twice next time
they decide to have an asshole for a
father besides my dad raised me tough
and I have nothing for him but rage I
mean I have nothing but it for him but
rage did I say rage I met rage I raised
you dad I raised you and if you're
wondering has any of this made the
Libertarian Party waver on Jackson the
answer is a deafening no Jackson won his
party's blessing for governor in March
when libertarians say they don't care
about your personal life they mean it
but opposers these are some great fringe
starters but it's up to you to get even
fringe here yes subtle there are still
too many reasonable candidates running
unopposed it's time to get out and beat
the establishment opposers there's still
room for your loud banshee cry are you a
traditionalist who wants to criminalize
ovulation are you convinced that Dairy
Queen secretly controls the supreme
courts are you an actual raccoon that
lives in a dumpster behind the show nice
you could be senator raccoon that lives
in a dumpster behind the show nice fight
the mainstream candidates opposers
oppose them the fight continues
[Music]